[Musica]
non rende niente ma niente questi
gavelli non rende niente non so se ve lo
ricordate house party simulator quel
gioco dove simula vi una festa in casa
va beh questo è il gioco in questione
raga non so quanto poco family friendly
possa effettivamente essere devo cercare
di essere family friendly al mille per
cento io in questo gioco cercherò in
questo gioco cercherò di evitare di far
vedere cose non farmi prete sarà
un'impresa però arcavata girati guarda
da un'altra parte
ho già fallito siamo da chiudere codec
almeno tu sei family friendly posso
parlare con te bene o che bello non
siamo a una festa non so se vi ricordate
sta roba
io commenti in non ne faccio ma che beh
ecco l'unica cosa a fine di prendere in
staccata suo gatto qua
siccome ragazzi ho pagato 14 salve 14
euro per giocare a sta roba piacere di
conoscere i limiti e jazz fare vino che
chi ha rubato 09 staff scheringa
franchetti ha rubato il termo va bene
allora parlerò con frank rai dove è
frank shaw frank no questo è patrick
patrick mi sa che non è tanto sobrio ha
anche perso la sua birra è l'appena
ripresa va bene lasciamo perdere patrick
frank dove hai messo questo ed eri dove
frank a lui e frank senti mi dai il
termine detto che non so cosa sia stanco
camon frank stai rubando dalle ragazze
prova che ha rubato un thermos perché
c'era dentro dell'alcol e lui non
sopporta l'alcol
vai via vade retro vade retro pop and
family friendly qua ok posso guardarlo
per te non ti conosco migliora bene devo
aumentare la mia reputazione con frank
così mi dà il thermos ama quale c'è una
bottiglia qui dietro a forse prendi
prendi ok lo aggiunta alimentari non so
che cosa mi serve casse che danno
fastidio e tornò a gesù che fastidio st
musica che dava è nome atto sei vestita
casse di armi la sospiri of these things
guarda ai miei video fa qualcos'altro
non stare sulla musica perché
gente possibile no questa è madison alla
chiamata per riaccendere la musica
maledizione non sai resistere senza
musica che problemi hai vabbè dai mentre
che lo accendono va da offrire string
allo zio qua che tanto ubriaco strega mi
ha ringraziato verrà realizzato il drink
porca vacca quanto ubriaco che sono
porca vacca poi è la vostra musica
schifosa basta che fasti mettiti la
gonna a posto ma stai zitta ma metti di
investito bene ma porca vacca ti puoi
mit problemi al cervello ai per girare
così in casa maledizione recco sentito
che qualcuno a dell'alcol è veicolo di
prima gli ho dato io perché è preso così
ma noi va bene aveva praticamente gli
spiego cosa mi ha detto perché era
veramente lunga vuole che io vada dal
tipo da cui ho visto mi raggiunge e gli
diamo una lezione che non sia quello
l'intento inizia parla con lui perché
lui il tizio shield marshall for friends
scrivermi non mi spaventa frank va bene
maledizione frank e lo sto tenendo fermo
ecco eccolo è arrivato su ferrero cioè
che piegava tutta sta prevedendo sta
cosa sia capace
eccolo quasi o nera è mera yemen a ieri
e noi che ce l'aveva in mano io l'ho
visto con giuro ci aveva in mano non ce
l'ho ce l'ho visto sei un min
nell'ascoli guarda che ha [ __ ] alla
stragrande divenire torna qui anche la
messa via la bottiglia farà lui ubriaco
ma sei scemo nel conto dei set
maledizione prova di salvare la
bottiglia c'era qui quindi è impossibile
che lo veda trenk muove eccolo ma frank
incastrato
vieni qua seguimi eccolo lì eccoli
perfetto ma dai ma come fava porca vacca
era lui che lo giura lui e la gara
nasconde nei pantaloni sono nei
pantaloni e mi questa dove spuntata
esattamente non c'era prima
salemi ok va bene
eccolo lì è come grande uomo fantastico
sei a posto
capita terriero e mi puoi spiegare il
motivo di questa cosa
emas o visto patrick che si nasconde una
delle tue br nei pantaloni quattro
macchine già prima l'allenatore la metà
bastava non oso pensare adesso nel
mentre quindi sto provando ad usare in
questo momento la combo patrick madison
centri adesso lui dovrebbe arrivare qua
ed è arrivato infatti ma stai qua un
attimo che ti fa si mena co patrick e tu
dovresti vedere la bottiglia in teoria
si spera stai qua stai qua stai qua non
uscì bravo però a portalone hai visto
bottiglia l'ha vista la vista scali st
l'idiota 6 hormone mera gli è pure tu
sta lì la bottiglia in caduta la voti
guarda guarda orbo che non si guarda
salio ecco patrick è andato giù
l'hai vista la scena era questa la
bottiglia guarda che ne so asim tabor
sud ed a questi scempi e caduta lui la
bottiglia è accaduto e accaduto a lui la
ma sei scema queste drogato drogato in
sta a casa maledetta maledizione aiuto
aiuto chiude chiudi mi troverà mai qui
dentro e così ecco ora prova a rientrare
idiota come si fa scappare da un idiota
basta chiudersi dentro l'armadio lì non
saprà neanche come usare una maniglia mi
rifiuto di credere che sia così demente
c'è anche se forte qua sembra che sia
chiusa e beh io non posso stare tutto il
giorno quindi esci marcato ho schivato
vai vai vai all'inizio ne chiedo io ho
detto meta che bello sto gioco non fai
più e gradasso schifoso lurido gangster
mediocre ti sei messo a posto la gonna
be ne possiamo parlare american stringer
wine ei suoi devono paio di una omessa
come far conoscere l'iniziativa mi
interessa era solo per fare il dialogo
qualcuno a un'altra birra
qualcuno avrà eccolo qua il casino che
sembra una cosa bruttissima questa ma
non è quello che pensate sociali
raccogliere la botti come faccio e qua
sotto ma non mi posso lo fa per passarmi
matti di thor kcal h sempre questa e non
so come ha fatto ad abbassarmi quindi
non so
come alzare parquet va e anzi un attimo
va beh in realtà stare così non è male
però non so come alza ecco qua e
aspettare la mia occasione
guarda frank guarda lo guarda lo guarda
lui guarda cosa ma guarda così in mano
guardalo ma no ma è un misto tizio ma
come è possibile
frank non c'è e ricompare la bottiglia
frank c'è e gli scompare la bottiglia a
cosa si urta post ha visto già visto hai
visto lui ha visto me hai visto lui
immagino chi prenderà la via mail lui a
me lui è lui a me lui lui lui lui ma non
me c'era lui la bottiglia sei stupido ma
c'e la li guarda scientemente ma
guardalo eccolo chiodi o mio dio toner
cause goldoni che ha mi ha buttato giù
frank porca vacca ma l'ho visto ragazzi
era cambiato un po rispetto all'inizio
fortunatamente è più bello evitare il
non family friendly è un casino fidatevi
per ora con quello che in house parti
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi mi
piace anche per i soci quindi la
descrizione questo che si schieri e noi
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo mi davano un
prossimo attentato rimorchio che sono
tutti falliti però da ragazza
[Musica]